here you know it's nearly the end of
unlv's fall semester here's a question
though what have students learned so far
oh boy so much today more than 30
engineering students are competing in
front of a panel of experts to really
kind of jump start their careers we sent
Candace Charles to look at UNLV there
with some of these inventions
oh is that something virtual reality
Candace hi good morning
well guys it is I was inside of a house
right now which is really cool there's
so much to see here there's more than 30
inventions from 150 students I'm joined
by two of the great minds behind one of
them they're trying to solve a problem
that we've been discussing a lot housing
issues this is Justin and Tyga thank you
so much for joining us this morning tell
us about your project well our project
just give a bit of background boxable
their business here in Las Vegas and
they're trying to tackle that problem
you know being having houses affordable
for for everyone so modular construction
it's kind of a brand new thing and
people are still developing a lot of new
ideas about it but one idea is the
connections how do you connect walls
ceilings floors together what our team
is doing is proposing a new way to do
that currently boxable they use screws
and nails to connect their homes what
we're proposing are panel locks to
connect those connections together so
we've designed our pollen panel locks
and we have a prototype to show you and
that would make it a lot cheaper right
okay okay that's cool tell us a little
bit Tyga how long did you guys work on
this project and how did you go about it
uh so we've been working on this project
for about six months uh pretty much from
the very beginning we had a goal of
winning the grand prize so from the very
beginning we had a daily meet weekly
meetings to discuss our objectives of
this project and uh how we're going to
compete in this competition and overall
coming up with the design and having a
design that we can propose to boxable
awesome Destiny tuggett congratulations
and good luck I know you guys want to
win that 500 bucks so good luck to you
guys you guys got a great project and of
course you can come check out their
projects and others who are starting at
one o'clock uh we got you covered with
details on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live from Marvel W Hall I'm Candace
Charles news now